IAN LAKE: What if you
had a Google engineer
to support your app
development and they
dealt with supporting
every version of Android
or building those
basic components so you
don't have to?
We've got you covered.
What if you, like me,
had spent ages building
a great modern UI,
only to find more edge
cases to handle to get
it great on every device?
We've got you covered.
What if your boss says you need
to support Google Cast, Ware,
TV, and Auto by tomorrow?
We've got you covered.
The Android Support
Library gives you
the tools to build apps faster.
We've packaged the
essential components
you need to build
a great app that
works on the huge variety of
Android devices out there.
It's like having
Googlers helping
you every step of the way.
I'm Ian Lake.
I'm here to talk to you about
what the Support Library is,
and why you should use it.
OK.
Hear me out.
Shouldn't the newest
version of Android
have everything you need?
It does have quite a bit.
But think of it more like
the foundation of a house.
A solid but inflexible base
to build your app on top of.
The Support Library
is the framing
you actually build
your app around,
letting you build
apps faster and focus
on the important part,
the unique experiences
only your app provides.
So maybe this
framework is helpful.
But what does that
exactly entail?
Well, we've talked about
the Support Library
as single library.
It's actually a whole
constellation of libraries.
Yeah.
There's a lot there.
Thankfully, you don't
have to use all of it.
You can choose exactly what
makes sense for your app.
So you may have
noticed this library
at the base of just
about everything?
That's the support-v4 library,
providing compatibility shims
and new functionality
for devices
all the way back to Android 1.6.
It includes support for
application components--
like fragments-- notification
enhancements for Ware and Auto,
and more.
Support for common UI
patterns, like paging
through content, tabs,
and navigation drawers.
And makes it easy to
load and share content.
As well as a ton of classes
to make your life easier.
And you see all those components
with stars next to them?
Those are unique to
the Support Library,
making this an essential
part of any app,
even if you're targeting only
the latest Android versions.
So they've got the big
one out of the way.
Phew.
Believe me, if they
were all like that,
we'd be here all day.
You may have heard of this
material design thing.
A fresh new look for Android,
iOS, the web, and everything.
The appcompal library makes
it easy to give your app
a material code of paint
all the way back to API 7,
through a custom theme and a
backward compatible version
of the AppBar framework.
I can't tell you
how critical this
is for making a modern-looking
Android app that looks great
on the latest devices, yet
doesn't have you pulling
your hair out supporting the
thousands of Android devices
out there.
So what else could there be?
You've got a beautiful app
using familiar UI patterns.
So the question becomes, how do
you take it to the next level?
Perhaps you have some
fantastic video content
that would look great on a TV.
The mediarouter library
provides the Cast button,
needed to get your
content to Google Cast
devices like Chromecast
and the Nexus player.
Or take it a step farther, and
build out a great Android TV
app using the leanback library.
Maybe your app has
fantastic pictures.
In that case, you might want
to use the palette library
to pull out prominent colors
from those pictures and color
coordinate your UI.
Perhaps you need a
bit more UI polish
to really make your
app pop off the screen.
The cardview library builds
a consistent card look
that fits in perfectly
with material design.
The gridlayout library
gives you an easy way
to align elements to a
grid without requiring
a complicated relative layout
or multiple linear layouts.
The recyclerview serves as
a more flexible and animated
replacement to
listview, making it
easy to build lists and
grids that react to changing
data in a beautiful way.
But maybe pixel pushing
isn't your thing.
You can use annotations
from the annotations library
to give extra hints
to the compiler
and catch even more
errors at build time,
rather than your app
misbehaving at run time.
Or you want to do some
serious parallel processing.
Renderscript is
perfect for that.
Finally, if your
code should ever
grow beyond the 65,000
method decks limit
that exists on
pre-Lollipop devices,
the multidex library can
keep your app building.
So there's a ton out
there, all serving
as the framing which can help
you build apps faster and work
across a wide range
of Android devices,
letting you focus on
the unique experiences
only your app provides.
You can learn even more about
all the parts of the Support
Library on the developer site.
I'm excited to see
what you can build
with the help of the
Android Support Library.